quand ce foyer du 19e arrondissement de
paris a été construit en 1977 il était
prévu pour 300 personnes des
travailleurs immigrés célibataire vingt
ans plus tard près de 1200 personnes y
résident essentiellement des immigrés
d'origine africaine ils dorment à trois
cadres voire plus par chambre est
aujourd'hui femmes et enfants dont la
une surpopulation tout le monde dénonce
alors détruire le foyer devenues
inadaptées et insalubres
pourquoi pas mais après les grands
fouillé ne favorise pas l'intégration
les gens vivent uniquement à l'intérieur
on a aussi un certain nombre de
personnes qui vivent sans papiers ou qui
n'ont pas de travail donc qui sort très
peu donc à l'évidence
la petite unité vient d'intégrer au
quartier serait sûrement un bon facteur
d'intégration
le vrai problème c est ce qu'on est
capable de produire en quantité
suffisante du logement adapté pour les
immigrés c'est ça la problématique bon
gardien qui se faire les résidents
accuse les gérants de ces foyers d'avoir
négligé l'entretien tout en percevant
des fonds publics
de leur côté les associations
gestionnaires évoque les effets néfastes
de l'économie un terme qui s'est mise en
place à l'intérieur des résidences
restauration coiffure confection des
services à moindre prix pour la
communauté une économie que dénonce le
rapport du député rpr un grand foyer
c'est souvent tout un village
reconstitué